sponsorships lots of artists are getting
them these days including myself
so how do you make that happen for
yourself i think the better question is
what kind of sponsorship do you want
what serves both you and the company
sponsoring you drex here from
drexfactorpoi sharing with you love of
poi spinning and flow arts to benefit
your body and brain and today i'm diving
into sponsorships what they are who
benefits from them and how to get them
before we dive in i just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing businesses
and what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard lane machinski and
becca beckham
thank you so very much for your support
for my work and my mission there are a
lot of different relationships that
companies have with artists out there
that are referred to as sponsorships
some involve free props some involve
promotion some involve commissions or
even being paid to make content so what
do they all have in common sponsorships
in simplest terms are an exchange
between a company and someone outside of
the company of items or services of
value in exchange for some form of
promotion why do this the biggest reason
is because advertising has changed
dramatically in the past decade
rather than being centered around tv
print radio or billboard ads now
companies frequently opt to do more
direct marketing through people well
known in the social media landscape the
term most often used for this in the
social media space is influencer a term
that many despise and or look to as a
negative or pejorative title but it's
also kind of a fact of doing business
nowadays put simply influencers are
someone their audience trusts and
relates to when they talk about a
product it feels less like a super bowl
commercial and more like a friend giving
you a recommendation and thus it feels
more personal intimate and authentic so
when it comes right down to it all
sponsorships engage with influencer
culture to create a form of advertising
wherein the person being sponsored
agrees to do the work of helping a
company build awareness for its brand
and or products many companies need to
get their name out there and build their
brand's credibility especially if they
sell products that are largely
undifferentiated or common it's all the
more important that their brand name is
one that is seen as trusted or
fashionable there's a reason you see so
many brands competing to get noticed
making hoops or contact poi it's
incredibly difficult to tell from a
glance whose specific product you're
using so building awareness of the
company's brand is essential to
surviving in our current social media
era the shortest and cheapest route to
visibility is to put those props in the
hands of flow artists that will produce
content featuring them to recruit a lot
of artists to do so and to give them
incentives to make a lot of that content
for artists there's a number of things
that get put on the table here one of
the biggest is just feeling seen having
a company offer to send an artist props
feels like an endorsement of either
their skills their content or both
it feels good and it also has to be said
that many of the incentives offered are
things that motivate an artist to do
more work and create more content
whether that's getting free props
commissions or getting paid to create
content sponsorships also offer a way
for artists to acquire things they might
not otherwise be able to it's also got
to be said that it gives us content to
create an excuse to make a new video or
post either to unbox our new prop or
show it being used for the first time
content builds audience so having
reasons to create more of it also helps
us build that audience and there's also
one more thing that i think is really
important and central to this
relationship that i don't think is
hugely obvious to people when they think
about sponsorships
and if you want to create good business
relationships this is absolutely
essential
branding an artist's brand is a product
of the expectations and relationships
they create with their audience and it
extends to everything from the visual
style of their content to what topics
they talk about and how they talk about
them one example look at the tutorials
that come from myself nick woolsey and
voitus dolbenko in many cases we're
covering exactly the same tricks but
nick's videos are fun and silly and
frequently appear to be improvised on
the spot
voitas are gorgeous to look at with lots
of incredible camera work and dramatic
lighting mine are usually shot in a
minimalist space with lots of slow
motion b-roll and are heavily structured
each of us have our own unique brand
while each of us creates content that
has a similar mission we do it in vastly
different ways and in so doing we create
a series of promises and expectations
for our audience and that's not just
about what or how we shoot but also
about the values each of us embody in
our content and companies also have
branding or brand identity while
sponsorships in many cases represent
exchanges of value from a material
standpoint they can also represent
exchanges of value from a co-branding
standpoint
companies and artists that believe in
similar values can both share audiences
by collaborating on content as well as
creating an ecosystem within which
people in those audiences can know whom
they can trust to go to for a variety of
different goods and services this really
is one of the biggest pieces of the
branding puzzle what they signal about
an influencer and a company's shared
values and the importance of extending
trust between their audiences so now
that i have gone off at great length
about the ideas and concepts underlying
sponsorship let's look at some of the
more common arrangements that get
referred to as sponsorships and flow
arts at their simplest one common
arrangement is for a company to give an
artist one or more free props either
with or without an explicit expectation
to make content with them
frequently this happens in the form of a
personal favor done if the influencer
and prop maker know each other or are
friends the risk in this scenario comes
because there's not a lot of incentive
in it for the influencer to produce a
lot of content they may do so in a short
burst but otherwise fall off quickly
because all they really lose is that the
prop maker may get a little grumpy with
them a much more official relationship
is one in which a company gives an
influencer or artist not just a prop but
also a promo code i guarantee you have
seen one of these before they're usually
a short string of characters customized
around the influencer's name or brand
identity that are entered at checkout
when purchasing from the company
they also almost always confer upon the
customer a small discount for their
purchase too these promo codes are super
helpful for companies because they can
generate metrics by which the company
can gauge the effectiveness of different
artists in generating sales as well as
how effective their marketing and
advertising efforts are overall on the
artists side of things compensation for
these arrangements can come in one of a
few different forms but what's probably
the most common arrangement is that they
receive a commission for each sale in
the form of store credit that they can
then redeem to acquire more props in the
future and i'll be real with you i'm
personally not a huge fan of this
particular arrangement and i think a lot
of companies lean way too heavily on it
it's an arrangement that does little to
support the artist other than making
them feel good in the short term but
it's popular because it requires little
to no risk on the part of the company in
most cases the materials for these props
have already been acquired by the
company in question so they're pulling
from a sunk cost rather than setting
aside money for advertising or promotion
effectively when offering store credit
in exchange for commissions it's really
close to just being free advertising for
the company when companies are just
getting started or trying to get on
their feet this can help them get their
foot in the door but it's also an
arrangement that they and the artists
they're sponsoring should revisit once
they have some momentum going the
arrangements that i prefer and think of
as real sponsorships are when an artist
receives a cash commission for each sale
they generate with their promo code this
can either be a percentage of the sale
or a flat rate for each individual sale
depending upon the company and the
arrangement now i like this arrangement
because it actually represents an
investment in the artist and their work
i can't eat props or pay the rent with
them so having an arrangement in which
those sales referrals have an actual
value that can be exchanged for
something essential in an artist's life
is also an investment in the longevity
of their work because otherwise at some
point they'll have to make the choice
between creating something with those
props and doing something that will pay
the rent
and i'm pretty sure i know how that
decision will go down for most people
there is one final arrangement that i'd
like to cover and it is one that can
sometimes also overlap with the other
arrangements i've outlined here and that
is being paid to create content how this
works is that an influencer artist or
content creator can come up with an idea
for some content that will feature a
product in a unique way or that is
likely to get attention the company
whose product they'd like to feature can
then offer to pay for the production of
said content in some cases this is to
subsidize the cost of creating said
content or it could simply just be an
incentive to get the thing done this
creates an opportunity for the artist to
up their game by putting more time
energy or thought into the content that
they're creating and it potentially
creates an opportunity for the company
sponsoring said content to receive more
viral attention
i've done plenty of examples of this
ranging from my monthly sponsored flow
videos to the videos on fire safety that
i did a couple years ago this
arrangement does carry with it the risk
of seeming like a conflict of interest
if the video explicitly endorses the
product in a way that feels either
calculated or manipulative
it can also produce some really well
produced and important content as well
though and honestly integrating a promo
code into said content to track its
efficacy and conversion rate
that's the best of all worlds right
there gives everyone metrics to work
with and to improve their work in the
future so with all that said the burning
question
how do you get a sponsorship literally
the first thing you need to consider in
this case is your audience what is your
relationship with them are these people
that know and trust you or are they
simply your friends liking your posts to
support you this is a really critical
difference if you have 10 viewers that
tune in trust your endorsements and
convert sales versus a thousand viewers
that do little more than leave a like or
comment
those 10 viewers are way more valuable
than the thousand i know everyone wants
to go viral but having a big audience
doesn't equal having an engaged audience
you really need the latter to get a good
sponsorship arrangement
think about what makes you unique and
why people watch you what are they
coming to get from you is it information
entertainment inspiration
understand what your audience wants and
it'll make sure that you maintain that
trust once you've considered this piece
of the puzzle think about companies
whose products you use on a regular
basis and why
what is it that makes these specific poi
this particular shirt this specific prop
bag one that you use on a regular basis
how do you think you could communicate
that to others the next step is to
approach a company that makes one of
these critical items and ask them for a
sponsorship
make it clear what value you think it is
that you bring to the table maybe have a
pitch ready or be able to talk to them
about your relationship with your
audience
do your posts generate a lot of
conversations are there lots of people
asking you what props you use in your
videos
at first the best you might be able to
hope for is a free prop and maybe a
promo code compensated in store credit
and that's fine everyone has to start
somewhere push that promo code and check
in with the company every month see what
content moves the product and what
doesn't
take feedback from the company and your
audience on ways that you can improve
how you're positioning the product and
even whether your audience is interested
in said product in the first place after
a year of keeping track of sales if you
want to keep your relationship with the
company make a pitch for why you should
receive a cash commission on the sales
that you're producing can you point to
how much income you've generated for the
company has there been an improvement
over time
if so
they should pay you for it it's also
entirely possible that a company may
approach you and cold call you if you're
garnering good engagement online
they may offer to send you props for
free in exchange for a review or
producing content around them think long
and hard about who this company is and
what values they represent before you
accept because it's important that they
overlap with your own brand and of
course
track your metrics and make sure that
you ask for compensation proportional to
the sales that you're generating for
them as for getting paid to produce
content
this one is sometimes hard and with one
exception i have always had to pitch a
company in order to land a sponsorship
like this it really helps to have data
to refer to for this if possible be able
to point to conversion data from promo
codes to show that you have a good track
record for converting sales also put
together a dynamite sales pitch
how would the content you produce
demonstrate the value of the product can
you find a unique way to present the
product as being especially useful and
or answer a common need or question with
it
get creative and please above all else
keep track of everything watch your
numbers and if they are good then use
them to argue for better pay rates in
the future use conversion data from one
sponsorship to land another sponsorship
all of this of course is dependent on
creating great content that connects
with your audience
it's dependent on them trusting you and
your recommendations
that should be your goal both at the
beginning and the end of the day with
this
that trust can be hard to regain if you
lose it so don't just go chasing props
or dollar signs
you can get a new sponsor that better
aligns with you in the future but
regaining your audience is a lot harder
don't take them for granted did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to keep the conversation going to help
other people find it and help my channel
grow this video would not be possible if
not for the wonderful support of all of
these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
bodies and their brains so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards and help me along in
my mission do check that out please and
thank you are you a sponsored flow
artist who are you sponsored by and what
arrangement do you have with them i'd
love to know so leave me a comment and
we'll compare notes in the meantime i'll
leave a link to playlist of videos i've
done on flow entrepreneurship down in
the description as well as up on screen
if you're watching on youtube make sure
to get outside to flow today and i'll
see you with another video real soon
peace